-Welcome back, everybody.
It is time for
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
Here we go!
-♪ Hashtags ♪
♪ Hashtags ♪
-Guys, we do this thing
every week where
I send out a hashtag
and I ask you guys
to respond to that topic.
This week, I sent out the
hashtag "MyHighSchoolWasWeird."
And I asked you guys to share
some funny or weird things
about your high school.
Within minutes,
it was a trending topic,
so thank you for playing along.
Really, thank you.
I appreciate that.
Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
#MyHighSchoolWasWeird
responses from you guys.
This first one's from
@robinjosmith.
She says...
That's embarrassing.
This is from @DontThinkso555.
They say...
-"Here's a toilet seat."
-"Yeah,
here's your toilet seat."
This one's from @HiTechReloaded.
-Ooh, yeah!
-He says...
Nothing weird about that.
-Yeah, nothing weird about that.
-This one's from @MaryOlmsted13.
She says...
That's pretty fun, man.
This one is from
@courtneygayle6.
She says...
-What?
A mop?
-The mascot is a mop.
-Spills.
-This one's from
@RileySmith IAm.
He says...
-Ooh!
Is it safe?
-That can't be real, right?
-Yeah.
-Could be.
-Dentist chair
under the high school?
-Yeah, for torture.
You got the toilet seat,
you got the tractor,
you're all set.
-This one is from @JamesMDodge.
He says...
-Oh!
[ Rimshot ]
Not too close. Spread apart.
-Yeah.
This one is from @ZeldaCorner.
He says..
[ Hisses ]
This one's from the @SusanSPatt.
She says...
"Alright, give me 500 laps.
-Backwards.
-This one's from
@CharlieHBaumann.
He says...
-Oh. Is that Will C. Wood
High School?
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-That is Will -- Must be.
They must have went to the
same high school.
-Yeah. Oh, boy!
-This last one is from
@sheardbeard.
He says...
-Oh!
-There you have it.
Those are our
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out more of
our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.